he's given a speech on leveling up
which has got nothing in it all last
night and today people have been saying
there's bound to be something in this
speech and there's absolutely nothing
the words leveling up look behind
nothing there
and we've been here before we had the
northern powerhouse
we had burning injustices now we've got
leveling up
nothing behind it this government is 11
years
in they need to be judged on their
record and he has a pledge to increase
investment and improve
services i mean what's wrong with that
he promises jam tomorrow that is what
this prime minister
does but there's no delivery
and the government has been in power for
11 years they need to be judged
on that record there's inequality
regional inequality across the country
prime minister can't look at that and
pretend that that suddenly happened and
it's not on his watch
but the words leveling up with no
substance are not going to get us
anywhere
they're no substitute for a regional
strategy
that brings money resource
infrastructure
skills all together around a regional
plan
that's what labour would do the promise
got two words and nothing behind them